and why aren't you in uniform demi
lovato is giving praise to drag queen
demetria cherry's latest transformation
into who else demi i'm excited demetria
whose real name is alex vargas is best
known for transforming into the
skyscraper singer on tick-tock
[Laughter]
and it seems demi caught wind of the
tick-tocker's newest illusion and why
aren't you in uniform
the artist couldn't help but share his
excitement to demi's praise in this
video rocking full demi glam of course
it's amazing now demetria isn't the only
one going through a transformation these
days
demi has been going through one
themselves i'm in a new chapter in my
life in february the former disney star
revealed to rolling stone that during
the pandemic they learned to be alone
telling the mad quote i think that at
the beginning of kovit i wasn't alone a
part of that situation was me not
wanting to be alone and then i really
came to terms with it demi explains that
ever since they started dating they have
always been talking to somebody or
hooking up with someone or in a
relationship and these past two years
have been truly transformative for them
adding that since being alone they've
become more secure in the person that
they are i love who i am and focusing on
their sobriety is also something demi's
been working on in january a source told
e.t the camp rock star wanted to get
back on track and recently swore off
being california sober which is a term
used to describe someone who uses drugs
and alcohol in moderation the source
adds demi's friends and family were
there to support them during their time
in rehab they wanted to start the year
off on a good path and this stay helped
them with this
what keeps me on this path is
i don't know there's a drive that i have
to stay sober because i know that my
life depends on it and when demi's not
busy focusing on their personal health
they're on the hunt searching for
extraterrestrial life in their new
supernatural tv series unidentified
[Applause]
[Music]
when e.t caught up with the confidence
singer they explained why it was
important to share their out of the
world experience with fans i think it's
important for me to talk about my
experience so that more people don't
feel alone in their experiences
i feel like
it's so important also to talk about
this because it raises our consciousness
you know it expands our consciousness
and that's what we have to do um in
order to make this world a better place
i feel like we're all our own worst
enemy or at least i am and i so i i
definitely
could see
how if anything is up there watching
over me they're definitely trying to
protect me from my worst enemy images
myself it's important for my fans to
feel close to me so if seeing me in a
more realistic light i guess with
reality tv
then i think that's important
[Music]
you